baby
these women from the Mayte Community
want India's government to take action
against fighters from the kuki ethnic
group they accuse them of attacking
their homes in the sugnu district of
Manipur
maranatham Singh is a retired Soldier he
says cookies targeted his property
despite a peace agreement with their
Mayte Rivals
we were comfortable in our houses
thinking nothing would happen because of
our peace committee they suddenly
started fighting at two in the morning
cookie Fighters attacked four districts
that night
the cookies are a minority tribal
Community which have preferential access
to land and jobs in parts of Manipur the
violence began nearly four weeks ago
after members of the majority may take
Community demanded similar benefits
jamtir gute and his family are cookies
who fled the area his son stayed behind
and was shot dead only days ago
they killed him after he was shot he
fell in a ditch next to the Village
Chief's house I've only heard this I've
not been able to see his body the
interior minister is visiting the area
to calm tensions but despite ongoing
talks neither side seems willing to
compromise
will continue to fight until we get our
demands that's principle there's no
turning back
we have lost so many life we have shed
so many blood we cannot go back
authorities say the situation is under
control but many here doubt that and are
living in fear of more violence Victoria
Gayton B Al Jazeera